you may have heard that mercury is
retrograde again but if you try to find
out what that means search results are
dominated by astrologers who believe
that mercury can make you spill coffee
on your favorite shirt or cause a car to
break down but if you set aside all of
those creative interpretations there's
actually a real astronomical phenomenon
underneath so let's start with the basic
layout of the solar system the planets
closest to the Sun move faster and the
outer planets move slower but they all
go in the same direction apparent
retrograde motion is when the planets
appear to temporarily change the
direction of their orbit they don't
change direction it just looks that way
from Earth it's an illusion that unfolds
over a matter of weeks or months in this
image Mars this photographed every 5 to
7 days between October 2011 and July
2012 once all the photos were combined
by aligning the stars in the background
it appears as though Mars looped back on
itself before continuing on its orbit a
retrograde illusion like this happens
when we lap an outer planet like we do
with Mars every 2 years or when an inner
planet laps earth like mercury does
every 4 months or so but for both
Mercury and Venus the illusion is hard
to actually capture since they're
located on Earth's day side not on our
night side when those planets are
visible it's only right around sunset
and sunrise but assuming you could see
it here's a diagram of how the Mercury
retrograde illusion would work this line
shows our view of mercury against the
background stars as mercury passes us by
our line of sight shifts so that for
about three weeks mercury will appear to
loop back on itself when viewed from
Earth it's simply a function of two
objects orbiting in the same direction
at different speeds if you stood on
Mercury you would see Earth make an
apparent loop to
I wanted to recreate this illusion on a
tabletop so I stuck a post-it note to
the wall in the background to represent
the fixed stars I grabbed a ball of
plate out to be mercury and my phone
camera represents Earth I took ten
photos of them orbiting in the same
direction with mercury passing by Earth
if you simply view the images in
sequence you don't really see the loop
but remember that the illusion is
relative to the background of fixed
stars so once you line up the images so
that the post-it note star is fixed the
retrograde loop appears
[Music]
here's another visualization of the
retrograde loop of Mars as Earth passes
it the bottom part shows the positions
of the planets and the top is the
corresponding view of Mars from Earth
the key is to always remember that Earth
is moving too so retrograde motion was
baffling to early astronomers who
thought that earth was stationary and at
the center of the solar system in the
second century Ptolemy devised a
complicated system of loops and orbits
within orbits to account for the
retrograde motion of planets that model
was accepted for 1500 years because it
seemed to fit the observations even
though it was completely wrong once
Copernicus showed that all the planets
including earth move around the Sun then
retrograde motion was easily explained
as an illusion so if there's any life
lessons to learn from Mercury retrograde
it's that we may be vulnerable to
illusions when we think that everything
revolves around us
[Music]
it's really frustrating how misleading
the scale is on every illustration of
the solar system so I feel compelled to
point out that the real distance between
Earth and mercury when those planets are
closest together is more than 6000 times
the diameter of Earth
[Music]